on this episode I get weird
Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 175 of the askgaryvee
show was a little bit of a different
intro I mean I've already like kind of
like all right do you rock you could put
on snapchat you have on the phone over
there um I'm not salty but I'm in a
weirdly passive mood right I'm usually
like what write up in it right all right
yeah let's get him to show Brandon
Hackford ask Sean West mentioned it but
this if stuff has been out for a while
and used to be against it why change um
I guess we talked about this the other
day right like you know like but that's
for an article right that was in daily
before daily before is up by the way
please
show a screen that's not clickable even
though it's with my own channel so
stupid um there's a couple reasons one
the the way we've ever secured the if
there's what I all we have one if going
on right now if this then that it's a
product you should all check it out it's
tremendously efficient thing I talked
about an upcoming article but I answer
here on the show for you as well
I don't like when Adam a ssin replaces
something that should be done by a human
right I don't like when the my name Gary
started showing up on email newsletters
with like a different font gary cuz it
tried to seem like it was personal I
don't like when you're not authentic to
the audience so the execution we have
currently a couple things one I like the
way it crops the picture accordingly to
Twitter so that works for me comes from
Instagram where I'm posting a lot to I'm
by hand I mean you know what actually
where's my phone you've got it right now
check this out guys this is actually
happening in real time right now it's
look it's even on my phone right now I
was about to do it but I didn't have
time let me tell you why I'm okay with
it so these are the two images one for
Twitter one for Instagram and the copy
for me to post right now on my social
channels because daily before just came
out right so what I used to do was why
save these two I post one an answer am
type and I post one on Twitter to me
that's not tricking the audience that's
just distributing content
like even facebook now I don't post
anymore whereas you know cuz I believe
that Facebook fan pages have become
content like sites and it's okay for us
to schedule and things of that nature
versus when you get a reply for me on
Twitter or were what I reply in the
comments of the any comment I've ever
made ever is me because I think if it's
my profile if it's a team Gary
Vaynerchuk it's just about authenticity
and the other thing that I have with the
eff desk situation is the URL is not
like Instagram URL it's actually if some
being very clear that it's coming from
somewhere else I guess I guess I'm
honing into my answer of what should be
automated and not I think that things
that are perceived as another hue as you
the human are doing them by the end
audience should not be automated but
automation can work as long as you're
not tricking and should work and can
work when it's contextual and just for
being the content so to me it's it's
really just a clarification on what I've
always believed which is if you're
faking the funk of doing something human
with automation that's bad but if you're
doing it for efficiencies of time and
there's no confusion by the end consumer
then it's good and so I guess it's an
evolution of the 2.0 version of my
because I don't think I've been clear in
the last decade of like you know Thank
You economy and things that I talked
about I do not think that you should
have your assistant or another human
being reply as you the efficiencies were
creating for the askgaryvee book you
know garrett is not you know and and the
rest of the team you know and riley and
all these good they're not gonna come in
and take my garyvee handle and reply to
people to buy a book because you're
gonna think that's me they're gonna use
the askgaryvee handle but the automation
of a photo that goes from Instagram to
use Twitter as a distribution channel
for that that is cropped properly things
that nature I'm comfortable with yeah it
that's that means it's on you and yet
you pause there for a second
you know waiting for an extra riff
got it that was just me swallowing my
gum I've swallowed every single piece of
gum I've chewed since 1983 well I mean I
just die from gum absorbing my body
there's plenty of time for gum tubs over
my body
Zacharias Zacharias asks what are your
thoughts on buying a franchise business
I love the show by the way thanks Zach
arias uh you know I think a franchise
business is probably very good for a lot
of people when Burger King and
McDonald's and and Sonic and and
7-eleven all these kind of things when
they're doing the marketing for you and
by putting that sign in from the store
people are coming into your shop they
deserve those dollars of whatever they
take it I don't know the models super
well but I do know a lot of people that
I've met in my life that are very
well-off and very successful and like
when you talk to them like hey how did
that guy do it or have that gal make
their money oh they own 79 KFC's like
you know like so I think the more
interesting question is is a franchise
business right for you if you're not
good at building brand if you're not
good at getting customers but you're a
good operator you work hard you're
looking for a steady income that might
be a great business if you're a great
like franchise business for me would be
idiotic because I'm a great marketer I
can get people to show up to things I
can get people to come in why would I
give up part of the action of somebody
that's doing that as well so if I was to
start a burger shop I would never go
with a franchise I create my own thing
but so I think the bigger so the
business model is fine it's been around
for 50 60 70 years it's a great way for
people with with less dollars to be
successful because a lot of the works
being done for you and so I like the
model but I think the question is is
that the right model for you make sure
you know your skill sets and all the
monies that you're giving up to
corporate by kicking them dollars are
they bringing you value for those
dollars I've definitely heard of people
that have started out in franchise
business realized ah crap I'm good at
these things
like it didn't there wasn't a marriage
there but for people that are not
marketers I don't know how to get asses
in seats I think it's a very good model
Shawn Shawn asked lots of people on
snapchat don't let followers snap them
if personal brands don't use it as a
two-way street aren't they missing the
point I think that they're missing
something I you know I've been
feverishly and fret you know send me a
message right now and snapchat and ask
me to friend you up and try to do as
many as I can probably snap chiz all
your messages don't save you certainly
go away if you get too many like I do
like I can't get in the queue so you got
to cut keep kind of pinging me a little
bit which thinks being like I can't
keeps rolling yeah like well you don't
get hundreds of messages an hour I'm
kidding I make that was just the razz
for fun you probably are you know so so
that kind of stinks but yeah I do I do
think that when you look at Mike who's
been winning on and some of the other
people like some of the early people
that are following the blueprint you
know by the way real quick everybody is
kind of yeah yapping at me right now
like oh you're pushing snapchat so hard
you guys have been very close to the
show nobody was saying that about
Facebook with me last year that's all I
talked about right or Instagram just cuz
it's the first they've never seen it
happen in an early stage they kind of
caught me mid Facebook thesis when I
started the show guys this will happen
again if this show continues and like
shmoo go muga like like that's what i'll
all talk about until I feel like I've
totally squeezed anyway yes look look
the answer is they're not missing the
point they're playing it means that
these personalities are playing the with
game not the depth game let me explain
if you just keep it as you're a content
pusher and people want to see you
dressed sexy or business advice or
whatever the hell you're doing if you're
just doing that and you're not engaging
with people because first of all female
personal brands have it different I mean
I've already talked to multiple of my
female friends on the that they're
getting from leaving their snapchat open
it's like it's like it's not good okay
that's number one number two for the
guys in the crowd it's a complete
no-brainer if you want to create depth
for for women unfortunately just life
it's a little trickier for me to give
blanket advice but clearly you know as a
matter of fact question of the day
whether it happened on Twitter or
whether it happened on email or whether
it's happening right now on snapchat has
me personally responding in a world
where I
Dunham's all by the way from the prior
question has that impacted how you feel
about me that's the question of the day
and the answers gonna be yes from a lot
of people right like people appreciate
effort and that engagement and so when
the questions being asked are they
missing the boat I do I think they're
missing an opportunity people are
affected by what they're outwardly
pudding but those if they took one
second and said thanks or hello or yeah
I said yeah Holland to some guy today
you know like if they do that I
literally believe that that that person
will pay more attention do more things
with them bizdev more with them care
about them longer and I think there's a
real ROI for that little extra effort
even though it's it's work
maybe it's work oh when did he put this
out gary vay-ner-chuk this is Damon John
the people's sharp I am huge fan of the
show that kind of reminds me of when Oh
dr. evil said who here's what bar job
anyway so now you know I have my new
book out called the power of broke d-roc
do me a favor can you just you're not
getting some love it's the funniest
here's my question for you well we all
know your history we know your history
of coming up from nothing and learning
how to turn around this amazing business
you have and now you have a huge empire
you have Empire were people like sharks
follow you and have a huge amount of
respect for you so I know you know how
to apply the power of broke because you
did it back then and you do it now but
now you're spending your own money on
your investing now in many many startups
and many people out there how are you
making sure that they are applying the
power broke because of course when
somebody doesn't apply the power of
broke they take in money they just think
they can go buy everything it's gonna
make a lot
better that's not the case and more
importantly after they apply the power
broke how are you making sure they keep
their mentality so whether they get at
this point in life they keep the power
of broke mentality to ensure success I
love them
d thanks so much for the question uh I
also love you're clearly a branding
genius you've said power broke so many
times that I think I'm gonna say power
broke 15 more times and like if you keep
saying it just becomes real um you know
then I I actually think it's impossible
to do I think it's very hard to teach
broke I don't know how to instill I mean
I'm forget about all my investments I'm
scared crapless of how I'm gonna teach
my kids that because they're gonna be in
the power of rich
that's right Misha and Xander I'm
calling you out you're soft so you know
I mean look I mean it's very hard to
instill those virtues and I don't know
that I've been successful as an
entrepreneur who's become an investor of
instilling that into my investment
investments at all I think what I've
done well is I've recognized what they
may be good at oh you're not the power
of hustle and broke and all that but you
know what you are you came from a rich
family you are seriously educated and I
think you really understand operations
and your number two looks like they're
pretty hungry and broke it like like I
really haven't I don't think it's fair
to to think that we can instill the
power of broke in the same way that I
don't think anybody can instill into me
the hash tag power of prep-school right
like like it's just not part of that DNA
and so I think I think I think that's a
challenge as a matter of fact I don't
read though I tried an audio book on on
my vacation and it didn't go so bad and
you can do two times speed it was pretty
cool so I'm really interested in how you
approach this with the book and like how
much like how do you how do you instill
hustle or things of that nature has been
interesting as outside investing it's
been very hard for me internally I do
think you can do it I've been very in
the same way probably mom and dad AJ
probably instill that into us right
because they worked hard good thank you
in the same way no grace do your thing
see he saw something so hard he's
nothing like like you know like so like
in the same way that I think my parents
showed me work ethic and it was
instilled in me I definitely see I I
think India works harder today look get
captured at write India do you truly
think that you work harder forget about
smarter do you think you work harder
because you've been so close to that -
if I'm the son of hustle right if to the
son what what but do you think do you
think you work harder because of it yeah
I don't you agree with that bro
it rubs off things 100% like I'm gonna
say power broke all day I do so I think
as an investor and I have empathy I know
what you do it's on TV I get it like
it's hard to do that from afar clothes
in the same way I think I'll be able to
pull it off with my kids I think I think
as an organization for a lot of you that
have 3 4 7 9 12 employees I do think you
can instill it and it's a very funny way
you do it by doing it only actions
actions actions actions the only way I
think you can do it is by you the leader
of a company acting a certain way and
people you agree with that I chose a
Jason to that one so so I guess they if
you can spend enough time with your
investments and they can I think one of
the ways that I'm you know you know
what's actually crazy I actually have
figured out a weird way how to do it
it's called dailyvee I've had multiple
people that are investments of mine
email me about the first three episodes
the fourth one just went out the three
episodes of daily mean like who you
might be working harder than me and I
haven't even made it yet and I've got
like so actions cool last one
Jing 1990s have you ever released a
subpar product or service if so why what
did you learn from it tons of times I
learned that if I don't apply all my
energy into something it can't be as
good as it can be I mean all day always
because I'm always testing I'm always
doing things like didn't we launched
Gary app
that I was gonna engage with everybody a
hunt like yeah V chat I mean like
absolute the answer is like a lot a lot
a lot a lot of things
gourmet library never took off like what
I learned is unless I am 100% all-in on
something it is vulnerable doesn't mean
it's not gonna work it means that it is
vulnerable and even if I have a great
leader in place like the the only way
that I've been able to guarantee success
is for me to micromanage the operations
of that I've had successes when I didn't
do that up front but but it's what I've
learned is I try to bite off more than
bite off more than I can chew
my vulnerability as an entrepreneur
always is big eyes right I think I can
do everything I literally think I can
force in my 17 hour days everything
through victory I've become much more
aware of that from 35 to 40 I still do
it because I get enjoyment out of it
like just having a lot going on is
exciting for me but I can afford that
enjoyment today versus you know and so
this means right trying to be smarter
about that to trying to make them be
very very enjoyable or have a much
better chance of winning but the answer
is tons of times I've launched subpar
products mainly because I wasn't 150
percent behind it and because maybe yeah
and really to give you guys more value
one thing I've learned a lot of times
I'll start with something and being 150%
in it and then like very quickly it
becomes 180 and 70 and they all have
different timings sometimes I've gotten
better at eliminating the things that
I'm 150% into and letting it sit for
more than like a week to allow myself to
see if it's still at a buck fifty and
then if it's at a buck 20 I'm like I'm
out but if it's a buck fifty for a month
or two and I'll go so yeah I mean if
you're not in it you're not in it good I
asked the question of the day I feel
like this office makes weird shows
Walter Isaacson wrote a book about
innovators right big fat new book he's
the guy did the Steve Jobs book it's
kind of interesting double-speed was
interesting he didn't read it which I
which I disrespected I think all authors
should read their audiobooks how many I
mean nothing oh I'd questions being read
but like they
answers is like the questions wasn't by
writing your questions but thanks for
the razz you keep asking questions such
a weird mood I mean like I mean this is
as weird as it gets and it's coming off
a wheat it's this back to back weird
there's people that like said les double
weird like bookend weird it's because
I'm in a very kind of like time yeah I'm
in a very weird mood
see you later